(soft music)
- Hey, come on in.
(upbeat music)
Yes, push and believe.
You got it.
- Time to Vine
some Brody Stevens.
- I'm in the bathroom.
- [Ben] Can I come in?
- [Brody] Kronberg, yes!
- [Ben] Say that again.
- Kronberg, yes!
You doin' a Vine?
[Ben] I'm doin' a Vine.
- Yeah, all right,
kay, direct me.
- Yeah, I was gonna do
like a beard, do a beard
and we'll get it shot.
- Here we go.
- Say, "More", when
you see my finger.
- More?
- Uh huh.
- Vines with Ben Kronberg.
(Ben laughs)
More?
- And then, uh...
(Brody spitting)
It's just soap.
- One more.
- [Ben] And then...
- More?
(Brody laughs)
- I like it, I like it.
- It looks like a guy
is finishing on my face.
- Do I have your
permission to Vine this?
- Yes, Vine it.
- I'm vining it, with
permission granted.
- Ben Kronberg,
Steven Brody Stevens.
Half-hour specials,
pushing, doing well,
getting the laughs.
Mature men vining.
You got it, back to Kronberg.
[Ben] I'm gonna dip my glasses--
- You're dipping your glasses?
- For luck, like a baptism.
- Real quick, what's
your writing process?
- You know, I keep
my notebook on me,
just so anytime I have an idea,
I can write it down, you know?
- I have my notes right
here, I'm in a bathtub
and I have my notes,
that's what comedians do.
- Yeah, don't necessarily
have like writing sessions,
I'll go over ideas
that I've written down
in the moment of
inspiration then edit later.
- That should go.
Write it down, take that
joint, take that bong hit
and start goin' nuts, yes!
Four-twenty, push
it, you got it.
Gettin' high illegally
against my doctors' wishes.
(Ben laughs)
Wooh, shit!
- Let me Vine this, let
me Vine, don't do that.
- Oh shit, oh shit!
- Don't do that.
Don't put it out, don't put
it out, don't put it out.
(laughs) You got it, it's good
and a real quick
positive energy--
- Positive energy!
- Let's check it.
How is it?
[Ben on Video] I'm vining it.
- Hey, we're havin'
a great time in here.
Thanks for catching on fire.
Steven Brody Stevens,
Ben Kronberg, yes!
Push and believe.
If you like the video,
tweet me @Brodyismefriend.
Let's go viral,
let's break records.
Let's put me on the map
with the help of you.
Got somethin' to say?
Leave me a comment,
'cause I'm readin' em.
Let's see that
view count higher.
It's like a telethon, you're
helping out Brody's kids.
Brody's gotta eat!
We can do it together.
Push and believe, hashtag yes.
(gurgling)